It's December 23rd.
It's two days before Christmas,
and my wife has abandoned me.
I'm trapped in mall traffic, sitting
behind the wheel and in the backseat
of my car Are truly two of the
most despicable and annoying human
beings I have ever met in my life.
My children, Clara is six and
Charlie is three, and there are
people in the world who will tell
you, these kids are brilliant beams
of light, but that is bullshit
because they are just like my wife.
They are spending their entire lives
trying to slow me down and prevent me
from doing the things that I want to do.
These are children who literally.
Stop and smell the roses.
My wife takes them to flower shows
because they ask to go to flower shows.
They stop me in parking lots and say,
look, dad, and point to the clouds and
say that cloud looks like a teapot.
Take a picture.
And I think I just wanna get in the store.
And they talk to everyone.
They talk to random
strangers all the time.
They are dangerously friendly children.
And my wife, my.
My wife loves babies and she's given this
to my daughter, so everywhere we go, my
daughter stops mothers with infants, and
she has conversations with them like,
what's the name of your baby, and how old
is the baby and breast or bottle feeding?
She's six years old and she's
just talking to everyone.
And I'm sick of it.
And on this day it is the worst day to
slow me down 'cause it's December 23rd.
I have to buy Christmas presents 'cause
I haven't bought a single present.
And I am beyond the Amazon Prime.
Click and save your ass date.
So I actually have to go into a
physical store and look at shit
on shelves to determine which ship
belongs to which person and what
will look good in wrapping paper.
And I'm angry this day
is going bad for me.
And my wife had the nerve on
this day to get a haircut.
And when she goes to get a
haircut, it is a three hour ordeal.
She is a woman with short black hair.
All she gets is a trim.
The trim iest of trims, a trim I
don't even notice most of the time,
but it takes three hours because she
begins the process with someone who
says, what are your goals for today?
That is shit that I cannot.
Abide bye.
And so we're going to the mall, but
we can't go to the mall 'cause my
kids are hungry and we have to be
outside because like my wife, no one
wants to ever be in the house but me.
I make enormous mortgage payments for a
home Nobody wants to spend a moment in.
So we go to Panera.
And when we go into Panera, I know
right away they've screwed up the floor.
'cause they have the brown tiles
except in an occasional red tile.
And if you have kids, you know that
that means your kids are just gonna
leap from one red tile to the other
and they're gonna knock people over
and land grilled cheese on the ground.
So I say, go to the dining
room and find a booth.
And I know they're gonna kill each other
while fighting over it, but I don't care
because they're not with me right now.
So I go to the cashier and she's new.
I can tell 'cause she's nervous
and so now I'm nervous and I
start giving her the order.
And I say, listen, my daughter
is allergic to peanuts.
Can you please note it on the order?
And she looks and she says, well, you
didn't order anything with peanuts.
And I'm like, ah.
I say, I know, but could you
just note it because she's
allergic and it's a good idea?
And she says, well, you really
didn't order anything with peanuts.
And what I wanna say
to her is, listen lady.
There's a substance in this world
that's basically in every food,
as far as I can tell, that will
kill my daughter if she eats it.
So could you please just fucking
put peanuts on the order?
But I don't do that because
I'm a better person than that.
So I charge past her.
I go past the counter and
into the employee area.
I take two steps into the kitchen
and I go, listen, I, you're
gonna make a grilled cheese.
And when you do, and then the
manager's right in front of me.
And she says, sir, and I say,
no, you don't understand.
Your cashier will not
put peanuts on the order.
And my daughter's allergic
and she's not gonna die today.
And the manager to her Everlasting credit
softens, and she says, sir, I understand
and I will take care of it, but you
need to get out of my kitchen right now.
And she's right.
I'm crazy.
And the kids have made me crazy.
My wife has made me crazy.
I get outta the kitchen,
she finishes my order.
I go to the dining room to find my
kids, and I cannot believe what I see.
They have chosen a booth in the back.
Clara is on one side, Charlie is on the
other side and in between there is a woman
who I do not recognize and an infant.
They're sitting with strangers
and I'm thinking, how am I
going to solve this problem?
But Clara knows what I'm gonna do
because she says, it's okay, dad.
She said, we can sit
with them and have lunch.
This is Hannah, and she
points to the infant.
And so I look at the
woman and she looks at me.
She gives me that sign that, I know
this is ridiculous, but let's do this.
And so I sit down with a stranger
at Panera, and Clara introduces me
to them, and we make some chitchat.
And then she asks the woman, she
says, where's Hannah's daddy today?
And the woman says, oh,
Hannah doesn't have a daddy.
And my wife.
And, and Clara says, oh, is it,
are you a mommy, mommy family?
And she says, no, it's just Hannah and me.
That's the moment when I look at this
woman for the first time and I really
see her and I see the bags under her eyes
and the slumping shoulders, and I see
the, the stuff that she has everywhere.
She's got the stroller and the
car seat and the diapers and all
the plastic paraphernalia that
we need to keep kids alive today.
The pacifiers and the bottles.
All stuff that I haven't seen in a
little while because my kids are older.
It's the first time I
really see this woman.
Who's taking care of this baby and
all of this stuff by herself and.
I'm so angry at Clara because she
has shown me the thing that I need
to see in this moment that I'm
wandering this world complaining.
'cause my wife left with me, with my
kids for three hours, three stupid
hours that I am complaining about.
I remember when Clara was born, I thought
we needed seven adults to keep her alive.
And this woman is doing it
on her own and she's smiling.
She's chatting with my daughter in a way.
I have not chatted with her all day, and
I sit there with these two brilliant beams
of light knowing I am never going to be
as beautiful and as wonderful as they are.
Thank you.